donc vous venez de voir que aujourd'hui
nous vivons dans un monde qui est ultra
connecté vous partager des informations
à votre sujet sur vos activités
ce que vous faites vos relations vos
goûts vos intérêts il a évidemment
absolument rien de mal à ça que la digue
harry dans la vidéo
encore faut-il juste savoir à qui
partager ces données avec qui pour
combien de temps pourquoi wes cates of
trouble vous partager ces informations
avec des entités que vous connaissez
comme un partenaire contractuel voir les
dates
pourquoi pour que ces entités vous
fournissent un service
il y en ad'autres un d'autres entités
inconnu dont vous ne connaissez même pas
l'existence vous ne savez même pas ce
qu'elles font le connaissez le pas leur
nom leur raison sociale comment elle
s'appelle qui collectent également une
multitude d'informations à votre sujet
pour les échanger avec d'autres sociétés
dont vous connaissez pas non plus
l'existence en 2013 le financial times a
estimé que la valeur moyenne des données
relatives au sexe à l'âge et à la
localisation de 1000 personnes étaient
d'environ 50 centimes ça ne veut pas
dire que nos données n'ont absolument
aucune valeur aujourd'hui
en fait elles sont devenues une nouvelle
monnaie si l'on veut dans cet énorme
marché qu'est la publicité en ligne
ce marché besoin actuellement je porte
selon les derniers chiffres plus de 120
milliards $ sur internet affirmant que
lorsque quelque chose est gratuit c'est
que c'est vous le produit à mon sens
cette assertion est partiellement
erronée puisque même quand vous payez et
vous restez produits même quand vous
payez une société ne va pas cesser
des données à votre sujet elle ne va pas
se ranger de votre côté et défendre vos
intérêts et doit quand même bien
continuer à faire de l'argent parce que
vous auriez finalement c'est un comprimé
aujourd'hui de plus en plus d'aspects de
nos vies sont numérisés automatisé voire
même transformé en donnait souvent
personne
si vous y pensez il ya 20 ans lorsque
vous voulez connaître la localisation
exacte d'une personne vous aviez besoin
dans détective privé qui vous coûter une
blinde
aujourd'hui il suffit de donner un
téléphone portable et une personne vous
aurez sa localisation
4 presque sans rien n'est facile et on
jure pourtant que ces données notamment
de localisation sont à la lime ou
anonymisées lorsque vous surfez sur
internet on vous annonce que cette
unification regarde aujourd'hui que le
site que vous visitez installe des
cookies sur votre ordinateur
et c'est qu'une qu'ils vont collecter
des données sur votre comportement ce
que vous faites en ligne et on jure
encore une fois et ces données ne
connecte rien qui permette de les
identifier et bien portant en début
d'année le mi6 a découvert que mon
analyse en trois mois de données
anonymes de cartes de crédit la date et
le lieu de quatre transactions suffisent
à reality fier 90% 20 millions
d'individus
et ça ce n'est que la pointe de
l'iceberg vous rajouter un troisième
paramètre qui est le prix de ces quatre
transactions
le taux monte à 94 pour ça donc
aujourd'hui vous fait miroiter le fait
que l'art identification n'est pas
possible
pourtant dès le moment qu'on a
suffisamment de données statistiques
d'un côté ils en arrivent ensuite à
croiser avec des données contextualiser
les données personnelles
il est extrêmement facile et donc tout à
fait possible de vous re et identifiés
et où viennent ces données
contextualiser ses données personnelles
c'est vous qui est partagé
sur les réseaux sociaux sur internet
lorsque vous utilisez whatsapp instagram
que sage même lors de vos conversations
privées
alors si vous vous échanger des e-mails
ils sont lus avant vous étiez certains
services spécialisés qui chiffre tout
mais les services les plus populaires
sont aujourd'hui surveillé toulouse ou
lorsque j'ai préparé ce talk je me suis
souvenu d'une phrase d'andy warhol qui
disait en son temps que dans le futur
donc aujourd'hui pour nous chaque
individu aurait 15 minutes de célébrité
mondiale
moi je me pose cette question
aujourd'hui les personnes qui naît dans
notre monde
ce qu'elle aura quinze minutes
d'anonymat ce printemps en collaboration
avec la hd est ce parce que je me suis
dit qu'avoir un soutien médiatique dans
le but d'avoir une possibilité les
minimes de sensibiliser la population
romande problématique de la protection
des données
nous avons lancé ce qu'on a appelé une
opération droit d'accès le droit d'accès
selon la loi sur les preuves sur la
protection des données en suisse c'est
un endroit qui vous permet d'exiger et
j'insiste sur le terme exiger des
entreprises privées de l'état qu'il vous
fournisse une copie de vos données
personnelles qui détiennent un site des
explications sur la manière dont elles
sont six c'est un droit qui est
inconditionnel vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous justifier n'ai pas besoin de donner
une raison pour laquelle vous l'exercez
la procédure est en principe gratuite et
on doit vous répondre sous 30 jours
jusqu'à maintenant je me suis attaqué
essentiellement à les entreprises
suisses et aux autorités suisses
mais j'envisage dans le futur de
d'étendre mon fils est de
d'aller regarder les côtés de grosses
multinationales j'ai pas besoin de les
citer ici ainsi que de services publics
étrangers
j'ai déjà notamment fait une demande
auprès des services de renseignements
britanniques
de manière générale les autorités et
entreprises suisses donc vraiment été
collaborative dans notre démarche
les délais étaient plus ou moins bien
respectés on ne m'a jamais demandé de
contribution financière à pas les sommes
colossales j'ai dû dépenser en courrier
recommandé
si on m'a presque toujours donné des
explications quant aux détails et tantôt
plus brèves sur la manière dont les
données ont été utilisées
il est arrivé que certaines entreprises
voir l'état omet volontairement ou pas
je n'en sais rien qu'ils mettent donc de
transmettre mes données comme s'il avait
quelque chose à cacher mais l'a
finalement n'était pas mon intérêt
principal ce que j'ai découvert c'est
que les sociétés actives sur internet
comme vous avez pu le voir dans la vidéo
hot stuff ont le bras long
en matière de collecte de données est
vraiment très bon à cet égard est ce
qu'il ya des personnes dans la salle qui
lisent les conditions générales
d'utilisation les déclarations de
protection des données
avant de s'inscrire sur un site ou
d'installer une application sur
smartphone ou leur ordinateur lever la
main six mois ça m'arrive maintenant
c'est des formations professionnelles ça
m'arrive aussi d'en rédiger parfois pour
des clients eh bien lorsque je lis ces
documents juridiques je n'arrive même
moi je n'arrive jamais à savoir
exactement ce qui est connecté collectés
pourquoi comment
comment les données seront traitées sont
très sécurisé où est ce qu elles sont
localisées auprès de qui parce qu'elles
sont déléguées un prestataire est ce
qu'elles sont échangé avec d'autres
données est ce qu elles sont transférées
à des tiers et si oui sous quelles
conditions sont-elles anonymisées
lorsqu'elles vont être transférées
chaque fois je pensais et lorsqu'on me
communiquent me donnait souvent je me
heurte à un mur j'ai soit un fichier 7e
soir pavé de pages papier avec mes
données
mais je n'ai pas du tout les clés pour
les comprend j'ai bel et bien mes
données personnelles et je ne sais pas
comment les lire
comment ils ont interprété je ne sais
pas exactement à quoi les ordres du
serbe
lorsque je demande quels sont les noms
l'identité des partenaires commerciaux
ou qu'elle ait donné ont été transférés
je l'obtiens gymnase et lorsque je
demande tout première fois j'ai souvent
de réponse la première scène c'est vous
qui nous avez donné ce qui est vrai dans
la plupart visons mais on dit aussi
parfois que ces données proviennent de
tiers de confiance
là aussi lorsque je demande qu'ils sont
ces tiers de confiance et ce sont 10
réfugie derrière le secret des affaires
en tant que juriste ça me fait doucement
sourire puisque je me retrouve ici face
à un conflit de droits fondamentaux d'un
côté la protection de la sphère privée
de votre liberté économique
mais en tant qu'individu je trouve
extrêmement dérangeant voire même
choquant que je fournisse des
informations à une société voir avec
pour en fournir un service et qu'ensuite
c'est société où l'état va aller piocher
à gauche et à droite des données pour
compléter mon profil ou ma fiche client
et que quand je souhaite savoir quelle
est la source de ces données on veut et
comme la donne pour jeunes secteur donc
il m'est impossible de remonter à la
source et donner un peu détiennent
certaines personnes voient des milliers
de sociétés dans
s'il y a trois choses que j'aimerais que
vous reteniez ce soir suite de ma brève
présentation ce sont celles ci la
première c'est évidemment rien les 28 et
que même si vous payez vos unités de
produit vous laisser des traces
on n'en avait même pas idée quand il
avait vu finalement c'est dans cette
vidéo qui va de 2012 donc de trois ans
rassurez vous que c'est pire aujourd'hui
la deuxième chose c'est que vous êtes
finalement amené et j'aimerais en fait
vous soyez amener à réfléchir lorsque
vous avez la possibilité de fournir les
données finalement les données c'est
quoi c'est vous ce que vous êtes
personnalité vient lorsque vous avez
donné certaines informations à des tiers
réfléchissez deux secondes qu amazon
vous demande votre numéro de carte de
crédit bien votre adresse postale
quoi de plus normal il va bien falloir
que vous payez pour le bouquin vous avez
acheté il va bien falloir qu'on vous le
livre mais est ce qu'une application
lampe de poche pour smartphones a besoin
d'une connexion à votre compte facebook
at elle besoin de votre adresse email
fonctionner at-elle besoin de votre
géolocalisation en permanence
on fonctionne absolument pas alors
désinstaller la refuser aller en
chercher une autre il rappelé à
plusieurs centaines enfin troisième
chose
n'oubliez jamais qu'aujourd'hui les
données personnelles
une nouvelle monnaie difficilement
quantifiable forte heureusement
non-imposables fiscalement à l'heure
actuelle mais on se rend compte qu'on en
a quand même perdu contre votre argent
vous savez mais se troue et de la banque
dont le portefeuille sous votre matelas
rachkov concassage que vous savez
est-ce que vous pouvez en dire autant de
modèles vous savez par exemple pour ceux
qui sont sur facebook ou est ce qu'elle
se trouve dans quel pays parce que c'est
bien facebook qui les a pas ce que c'est
un tiers comment elles sont jeunes et
bien je crois qu'il est temps
aujourd'hui que montrent ces sociétés
ainsi qu'à l'état qu on s'en fiche pas
de ce qu'ont fait nos jeunes est un l'un
des moyens qu'on a aujourd'hui
même si vous parlez dérisoire c'est
justement d'exercer votre droit d'accès
à vos données demandées à l'état a
demandé aux sociétés privées quand vous
qu'on vous explique
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait il y en a
suffisamment peut-être un moyen de
changer les choses
même si aujourd'hui quand on y pense je
suis sûr que c'est ce que vous pensez
tous a plus rien à cacher mais attention